valérie pécresse secrétaire général
délégué de l'ump et ancien ministre du
budget est l'invité de preuves par 3
bonsoir à sa merci d'être avec nous ce
soir
les déficits qui se creusent la
croissance en panne le tableau semble de
plus en plus noir pour l'économie
française
mais l'opposition auraient-elles d'autre
solution que la rigueur que vous aviez
d'ailleurs enclenché on va en parler
valérie pécresse au cours de cette
émission nadège pull jacques de l'
agence france-presse notre partenaire
ainsi que dailymotion désormais et puis
perrine tarneaud de public sénat nous
rejoindre on en parle d'abord donc de la
croissance avec laurent fabius donc et
qui se fait une spécialité de briser les
tabous
après celui sur l'objectif impossible
des 3% de déficit donc celui sur la
croissance de 0 8% inatteignable cette
année c'était un secret de polichinelle
on peut le dire pour les économistes
parce que la france qui n'est pas la
seule à être en panne on peut le dire
est confronté à un problème qui dépasse
nos frontières valérie pécresse
d'abord il faut souligner que c'est le
désordre le plus total au gouvernement
c'est le désordre sur la croissance
puisque françois hollande refuse de
réviser encore ce soir les chiffres de
la croissance et laurent fabius annonce
0,2 au lieu de 0,8
c'est le désordre sur les déficits et
c'est le désordre sur les impôts
puisqu'on ne sait pas si on va augmenter
encore les impôts ou si comme monsieur
cahuzac l'aï promis on ne les augmentera
plus à partir de 2013 alors on a
l'impression d'un hollande sans cap d'un
hollande sans boussole et je dois vous
avouer que soit le gouvernement nous
cacher ses intentions et c'est grave
soit pire encore il est dépassé par les
événements c'est encore plus grave alors
tout de suite le premier ministre vous
appelle à la modestie en raison et bien
du bilan que vous avez laissé en termes
de croissance de dette de chômage de
commerce extérieur quelques que
répondez-vous au premier ministre je lui
réponds qu'il faudrait d'abord qu'il est
un cap parce que nous avions un cap
depuis 2010 nous avons pris comme 4
situe à 8% de déficit
nous avons pris un cap la réduction des
déficits sans casser la croissance et la
réduction des déficits sans casser
la croissance ça passait par une
politique qui a préservé les
investissements et qui a baissé les
dépenses de fonctionnement préserver les
investissements baisser défense de
fonctionnement c'est le contraire de la
politique de françois hollande qui a
choisi le tout impôt et on voit revenir
la gauche laxiste celles qui augmentent
les impôts et qui supprime toutes les
mesures d'économies du gouvernement sa
revente pouvez-vous dire ça alors que
les lettres de cadrage son parti vous le
savez bien bien en avance cette année
pour les ministres on leur serre la vis
vraiment de tout côté il ya un effort
incroyable considérables même en matière
d'économie c'est ce que dit le
gouvernement mais la cour des comptes
vient d'affirmer lé inverse
vous parlez de 2014 nous sommes en 2013
nous sommes en 2013 avec un budget dont
nous savons qu'il n'est plus sincères
puisque la perspective de croissance ne
sera pas atteinte qui n'est plus sincère
parce que les déficits vont exposer
pourquoi les déficits vont exploser
tout simplement parce que toutes les
vannes des dépenses sont rouvertes
monsieur hollande a supprimé le un sur
deux monsieur hollande a que des noirs
des fonctionnaires dont les salaires sur
deux qui part avec le traite la revue
générale des politiques publiques
il a supprimé au quai un nouveau nom
pour l'instant il l'a supprimée pour
2013 à l'hystérisation il en a recréé
une pour l'instant on n'a aucune mesure
concrète il a supprimé toutes les
mesures d'économies sur le train de vie
de l'état que nous avions prises il a
super supprimer la convergence des
tarifs à l'hôpital il a supprimé la
franchise sur l'aide médicale d'état
pour les étrangers en situation
irrégulière et cette aide médicale
d'état est en train d'exploser elle
atteindra un milliard
il a annoncé par dont trois milliards de
mesures sur la conférence pauvreté sur
le contrat génération qui ne sont pas
financés la dépense est en train
d'exploser on entend le premier ministre
dire qu'il met en oeuvre une gestion
rigoureuse des finances publiques ce
n'est pas le père la rigueur pour vous
alors c'est tout le contraire
et monsieur ayrault en plus s'approprier
l'héritage nicolas sarkozy alors bon
ici dénonce vos responsabilités nos
subventions monsieur grossiord en 2012
monsieur ayrault se vante d'avoir baissé
les dépenses mais en 2012 qui a fait
voter des baisses de dépenses c'est vrai
qu'on leur connaît mon parti on attend
des comptes en totalité des baisses de
dépenses et nous puisque je vous
rappelle que la gauche avait voté contre
elle avait voté contre le jour de
carence pour les fonctionnaires elle
avait voté contre toutes les mesures
d'économies et aujourd'hui en 2013
toutes les vannes de la dépense sont
ouverts et du coup nous nous retrouvons
avec comme seul outil de réduction des
déficits
l'impôt alors concernant cette révision
à la baisse de la croissance donc on va
retenir le chiffre évoqué par laurent
fabius
02 03 % vous rendez compte deux cas
cités situation dans laquelle lorsque
sheen service sera ce sera moins
peut-être peut-être que vous êtes encore
plus pessimiste que le ministre des
affaires étrangères où on peut dire que
le chiffre de 0,2 pour cent est
totalement crédible elle ce n'est pas
celui du gouvernement et si on prend pas
ce chiffre
si on prend le chiffre de 0,2 pour cent
ça veut dire nous sommes en février
qu'il manque 6 milliards d'euros sur la
question des recettes similaires sur
garderie le mans s'est retrouvé 6
milliards de plus
attendez il manque 6 milliards de
recettes et les dépenses ont déjà dérapé
de plus de 3 milliards d'euros
voilà donc on est aujourd'hui avec 10
milliards d'euros en manque dans le
budget le budget 2013 n'est plus un
serge lady il doit être revu et la
perspective du retour à l'équilibré en
2017 à laquelle s'accroche
monsieur ayrault est aujourd'hui
totalement improbable même vous n'y
croyez pas sur la sur le quinquennat
mais il faudrait pour cela faire des
réformes structurelles
il faudrait pour cela avoir une vision
de la dépense qui ne soit pas seulement
un rabot budgétaire qui soit vraiment en
profondeur et c'est pour ça que demain
j'organise la convention de mon club
d'idées le labo des idées
à vendre et on proposera un certain
nombre de vraies réductions de dépenses
des réductions dans les temps cela l'a
par exemple la fusion département région
avec la suppression de toutes les
actions cofinancé par les deux
structures
aujourd'hui les régions et les
départements agissent ensemble dans le
monde change et avec des fonctionnaires
et tout ça ça un coup qu'on a estimé à
peu près 18 milliards d'euros moi ça
c'est sûr que l'empilement des
structures administratives françaises ni
la droite ni la gauche n'a osé s'y
attaquer jusqu'à présent mais c'est faux
monsieur grossiord nous avions fait le
conseiller territorial qui était le
premier
la première les prémices d'une fusion ça
fait penser mais à partir du moment où
les collectivités ont les mêmes élus
vous comprenez que c'est beaucoup plus
simple pour fusionner ensuite les
services administratifs et que tout le
frein à la réforme des collectivités
locales venaient du fait qu'il y avait
deux assemblées une assemblée conseil
régional une assemblée conseil général
la gauche a rétabli ce système elle a
rétabli le mille feuilles des
collectivités locales c'est une faute
vous ne reconnaissez pas le courage de
la gauche de s'attaquer à cette
situation vous vous estimez qu'il laisse
filer la dépense est ce que vous
souhaitez quand même bon courage à celui
qui vous a succédé au budget jérôme
cahuzac est donc je le disais tout à
l'heure déjà envoyé les lettres de
cadrage au ministre les discussions va
être houleuse comme jamais parce que
certains ministres commencent à dire
attention c'est pas possible de
politiques d'austérité
pourquoi les discussions vers d'être
houleuse et pourquoi et parce qu'il
revient de la crise et à ce qu'un bios
mais parce qu'à tromperie dès le départ
il ya tromperie dès le départ
françois hollande leur a fait croire
depuis son élection en mai dernier qu'on
pouvait ne pas faire d'effort et
d'économie alors évidemment les
ministres à qui on n'a pas demandé
d'économies cette année
on leur dit l'année prochaine il faut
faire des économies ils y sont ils sont
un peu surpris ils sont pris
complètement à rebrousse poil mais
j'ajoute que nous avions
fédérer forment le mot réforme désormais
mais le mot réforme est désormais de
tabou mais c'est des réformes qui
permettent d'économiser vraiment de
l'argent
là on va leur faire des coupes
budgétaires et on va leur demander de
trouver de l'argent mais ça ne se trouve
pas comme ça il faut faire des réformes
il faut décider par exemple que on va
supprimer telle mission nous par exemple
nous avions décidé d'externaliser tout
l'entretien des voitures de l'état par
exemple ça s'appelait la revue générale
des plus de public on avait donné toutes
les voitures de l'état à gérer à des
partenaires privés
ça c'est une réforme c'est une référence
structure vous avez dit que la cour des
comptes effectivement avait salué vos
efforts d'économies budgétaires valérie
pécresse mais vous aviez vous aussi
augmenter les impôts on n'a pas la
mémoire courte quand on est contre il
avait alors dit la barque fiscale
monsieur gros sinon je le reconnais pas
nous avons augmenté les impôts mais nous
avions augmenté les impôts dans un
équilibre entre baisse des dépenses et
hausses d'impôts
là il n'y a plus d' équilibre la balance
est totalement déséquilibré on est dans
l'overdose fiscale et moi je le dis au
gouvernement
le gouvernement ne peut plus augmenter
continuer d'augmenter les impôts il doit
il ne doit plus avoir recours à l'armé
fiscale
elle est en train de tuer la croissance
parce que les ménages ne consomme plus
parce que les entreprises n'investissent
plus et pire parce qu'elles sont en
train de se délocaliser à l'étranger ou
alors de passer au travail au noir
un commentaire sur françois hollande qui
s'est rendu quelques heures en grèce à
athènes elle était beaucoup mieux
accueilli qu'angela merkel vous avez vu
il a prôné la borne là bas la croissance
comment vous recevez ce genre de
discours présidentiels
vous me permettrez de dire que le
président de la récession qui prône la
croissance en grèce
pardon mais c'est un peu ridicule on n'a
pas de leçon à donner aux grecs en la
matière surtout compte tenu du fait que
hollande à concasser les moteurs de la
croissance en france
un mot sur les avertissements répétés de
didier migaud donc le président de la
cour des comptes
est ce que vous le voyez comme lanceur
d'alert éventuellement qui concocte ce
qu'il dit en harmonie avec le
gouvernement je crois que didier migaud
a une vraie indépendance de pensée quand
il dit que le gouvernement ne tiendra
pas ses objectifs de déficit que son
discours sur la baisse des dépenses
c'est de la fiction que l'overdose
fiscal est atteinte c'est qu'il faut
s'arrêter je ne pense pas que ce soit
des paroles qui plaisent énormément au
gouvernement d' accor et quand il fait
une vigile c'est un lanceur d'alert
utile d'apprentis très utile qu'il faut
écouter et ancien homme de gauche un
homme de gauche à quelques anciens
députés socialistes il faut écouter donc
même quand il suggère un débat sur la
fiscalisation des allocations familiales
donc mais moi je ne comprends pas didier
migaud parce que la veille nous dit on
n'est plus là sur sur cette question là
simplement sur cette question là parce
qu'il dit la veille
l'overdose suisse qu'elle est atteinte
et eddy le lendemain on peut re
fiscaliser les allocations familiales la
question de la fiscalisation des
allocations familiales et des idées oui
parfois de droite à gauche on se
souvient de bruno le maire qu'il avait
suggéré ya pas si longtemps on entre
dans un autre contexte dans un contexte
beaucoup plus apaisé on n'aurait pas
fiscaliser les heures supplémentaires ou
on envisagerait pas une taxe écologique
de 6 centimes par litre sur le diesel où
on ne serait pas en train de geler le
barème de l'impôt sur le revenu on
n'aurait pas plafonner les niches
fiscales mais vous rendez compte on
n'aurait pas augmenter les cotisations
sociales pour les emplois à domicile
vous vous rendez compte de lui
l'avalanche de taxes qui s'est battue
sur les classes moyennes les pyrénées de
déficit pour la branche famille ça c'est
quand même lourd déficit oui mais
peut-être qu'il y a à faire pardon mais
un tri dans toutes les prestations
familiales peut être qu'aujourd'hui les
77 prestations familiales qui sont
versés mériterait d'être revisitée
réévalué au regard de leur impact sur
les familles vous êtes pour
l'universalité comme l'on dit des
allocations familiales
on les donne à toutes les familles quel
que soit leur niveau de revenu c'est ça
je pense si vous voulez je pense que
augmenter les impôts toujours la
solution de facilité dont fiscaliser les
allocations familiales
c'est la solution tacite et c'est
beaucoup plus facile que de dire on va
réformer la formation professionnelle
par exemple 32 milliards d'euros un
maquis toutes les chambres des comptes
des régionales des comptes nous disent
qu'on ne sait pas quelles sont les
formations qui sont utiles
on sait bien qu'on a énormément de
métiers en tension pour lesquels il
n'existe pas de formation
donc on a un vrai chantier de la réforme
de la formation professionnelle
celui de l'assurance chômage celui de la
de la réforme de l'hôpital
tout ça c'est des sujets que le
gouvernement n'apporte pas alors deux
petites questions avant d'accueillir
nadège pilsen de l' agence france-presse
et on parlera de l'ump assez à propos
des allocations familiales il est un
sénateur centriste monsieur pozzo di
borgo qui propose une modulation
régionale par exemple ait dit ça coûte
beaucoup plus cher d'élever des enfants
à paris pour tracer vous là ce sujet
ouvre une boîte de pandore parce qu'il
n'y a pas seulement les politiques
familiales ya aussi les aides au
logement à ce moment là il ya aussi le
cimic qui pourrait être régionalisées
alors je pense qu'on ouvre une boîte de
pandore avec ses sujets mais qui n'est
pas une question
dépourvu de sens cette signification
la vérité c'est que on a un niveau de
vie qui est enfin qui est beaucoup plus
cher en île de france par exemple la
maison très riche les conséquences on
peut en tirer dans la rue distribution
justement la vérité c'est que les
salaires sont aussi plus élevés rare de
france
donc faut regarder ça d'un peu plus près
dernière question enfin construire le
problème c'est le loyer qui vint le
principal budget des familles et qui est
beaucoup trop élevé en ile de france
parce qu on y construit pas assez de
logements
autre question à budget constant oriella
on n'ouvre pas le robinet
ministère de la ville une certaine
développé un serveur de mesure
aujourd'hui pour les quartiers notamment
cette offre de 5000 euros pour employer
des jeunes issus des cités qu'en pensez
vous et vous savez moi je il faut des
emplois aidés les emplois aidés vous
savez c'est nécessaire c'est des
solutions d'urgence à des situations
d'urgence j'en ai finances est il normal
que le gouvernement finance mais on peut
pas faire des emplois aidés l'alpha et
l'oméga de la politique de 5000 euros
pour les gars je vois le président de la
région ile-de-france socialiste jean
paul huchon financer les emplois jeunes
des emplois d'avenir avec de l'argent
que le dernier état pour faire de
l'apprentissage
eh bien je dis qu'on a on fait
totalement fausse route et que c'est par
l'insertion dans l'entreprise conviendra
un vrai emploi à la plupart des chaînes
allez on va parler maintenant de l'ump
valérie pécresse avec donc un adage
peljak de l' agence france-presse
l'ump qui veut donc sanctionner le
gouvernement à travers une motion de
censure qui devrait être débattue à la
mi mars à ce sera la première du
quinquennat et elle fait sourire par
avance le premier ministre jérôme rabier
en leader de l'opposition c'est jean
françois copé qui montera à la tribune
pour porter le fer contre le
gouvernement le président de l'ump
proposera ce qu'il appelle un véritable
big bang économique
jean marc ayrault lui se délecte
d'avancé de cette motion pour
s'expliquer sur le bilan de la droite
au ps on préfère ironiser ce que je sais
c'est qu'à eu de big band croûte avec la
gestion de la droite
j'ai plutôt l'impression que la droite
veut à nouveau nous proposer une big
austérité une motion de censure qui n'a
aucune chance d'être votée par une
assemblée majoritairement de gauche
alors gadgets inutiles ou outils
parlementaire de forme pour enfin parler
du fond ce sera une occasion à la fois
de sanctionner le gouvernement et en
même temps de tracer un certain nombre
de pistes d'avenir et de restructuration
et de remise à plat nos finances
publiques
une motion de censure qui a comme un air
de déjà vu puisque sous le quinquennat
sarkozy pas moins de trois avaient été
déposées françois hollande et jean marc
ayrault en avait personnellement défendu
et le premier ministre actuel fustigeait
déjà à l'époque la politique économique
de la droite croissance remettiez vous
et nous entrons en récession confiance
nous demandiez vous et c'est la défiance
qui est au rendez vous la motion de
censure serait donc finalement un outil
pour une opposition en manque de
visibilité
une motion de censure sur la dépense
publique il va falloir qu'ils étayent et
qui trouvent des arguments en tout cas
une chose est sûre c'est qu'il trouvera
un premier ministre qui lui répondra
derrière un premier ministre qui affiche
la volonté d'en découdre
c'est toute la majorité qui s'échauffe
tout particulièrement sur les choix de
politique économique où il considère que
la droite a laissé une ardoise cacher et
en l'occurrence le choix du sujet à mon
avis n'est pas un bon choix pour eux est
un excellent choix pour nos donc nous
allons y travailler pour je dirais faire
une jolie prise de judo qui les retrouve
un peu écartelée sur le tatami une jolie
joutes orales en perspective en forme de
remake de la présidentielle où droite et
gauche c# et déjà sur le bilan des
années sarkozy mais qui sait la limite
de la motion de censure n'aura aucun
impact sur la politique du gouvernement
voilà question que jean françois copé le
président vous les prenez à l'occasion
de la du débat de censure qu'il va
proposer un big bang
qu'est ce que c'est que ça l'opposition
doit s'opposer mais elle doit aussi
proposer et aujourd'hui on l'a bien vu
hollande est le seul président de la
république qui fait rimer croissance
avec dépenses eh bien nous nous allons
dire ce qu'est pour nous une vraie
politique de croissance et simple est
longue
abbas et une politique de croissance et
de création d'emplois comment faire
aujourd'hui pour sortir la france de la
récession
vous avez eu françois bayrou avait dit
aujourd'hui que si c'était à refaire il
revoterai pour françois hollande
ça vous inspire quoi ça françois bayrou
avait une parole très juste pendant la
campagne présidentielle il avait mis en
garde les français contre une gauche de
l'impôt déficit et de la dette
eh bien il a aujourd'hui au pouvoir
cette gauche et il a voté pour elle
il recommence eh bien je dirais errare
humanum est né perd sable est
perseverare diabolicum
il le confie t-il il reconnaît qu'il ya
des tonnes d'interrogations sur la
politique économique du gouvernement
mais les rognons de l'alternance
nécessaire
et bien si l'alternance s'est plongé la
france dans la récession et dans le
déclin je dirais qu'il valait peut-être
mieux s'en passer c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour vous pour 2017 si parle
d'alternance à ça peut le conduire
effectivement à réviser son vote pour
2010 est bon on va plus parler de l'ump
maintenant une question toute simple est
ce que l'ump aujourd'hui est en état de
marche
l'ump est au travail là je quitte à
l'instant une réunion nous avons
travaillé sur les investitures des
municipales et je crois que nous devons
partir à la reconquête des territoires
avec des équipes motivées qui voudront à
la fois sanctionné des gestions nicipal
mais aussi apporté une contre une
alternative à la politique du
gouvernement
mais il ya quand même des sujets sur
lesquels vous n'êtes pas tellement
audible je prends un exemple aujourd'hui
il ya eu le projet de loi le vote sur le
projet de loi concernant la réforme
bancaire
certains d'entre vous comme monsieur
gérald darmanin qui est donc député ump
du nord
il a voté pour d'autres voté contre
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire qu'il
ya une d'hésitation à l'ump qui est du
cafouillage ce que vous reprochez
d'ailleurs au gouvernement et chez vous
est ce qu'il ya aussi du cafouillage il
ya de la diversité la diversité de
sensibilité la loi bancaire
il y avait des bonnes choses et il y
avait des mauvaises choses pour moi
les mauvais aspects l'emporter sur les
bons mais il y avait des bonnes choses
en matière de supervision bancaire qui
d'ailleurs s'inscrivait dans la droite
ligne de ce que nous avions fait c'est à
dire plus de transparence et de contrôle
sur les banques ça c'étaient les bonnes
choses ce qui allaient dans le mauvais
sens c'était de faire une loi en avance
qui allait mettre des boulets au système
bancaire français par rapport au reste
du système européen est aujourd'hui en
termes d'emploi
vassallo avec notre priorité on doit
préserver l'emploi y compris dans le
secteur bancaire et si l'ump parfois
inaudible madame pécresse c'est
peut-être parce qu'ils viennent double
commande au pouvoir chez vous on a vu
vous avez fait un accord au mois de
décembre qui a semble-t-il régler les
problèmes entre fillonniste et copéiste
depuis il ya une double commande puisque
vous êtes partagés les rôles
enfin les rôles et responsabilités au
parti entre que pro-copé pro fillon mais
est ce que tout ça c'est pas un système
un petit peu paralysant pour vous je ne
le ressens pas comme ça j'ai
l'impression justement que nous avons
fait cet accord en adultes responsables
conscients de la tante de nos électeurs
et que nous travaillons à la fois nous
opposer à proposer et aussi à préparer
les municipales mais c'est pour ça aussi
que j'en prends ma part quand je réunis
le labo des idées pour proposer 20
milliards d'économies supplémentaires à
faire dès maintenant pour financer le
crédit impôt compétitivité la seule
mesure de croissance de françois
hollande qui pour l'instant n'est pas
financé je pense que je fais acte de
responsabilité j'apporte ma pierre à mon
parti à ma famille politique l'ump on a
beaucoup vu et entendu jean françois
copé jusqu'ici beaucoup moins françois
fillon qui était relativement discret
jeudi relativement à ce qu'ils
envoyaient des communiqués et
réagissaient m'enfin on le voyait peu
moins cette semaine ça va repartir
puisque avant il a plusieurs oui ça va
repartir cette semaine pour monsieur
fillon
il va faire notamment un déplacement en
alsace enfin surtout surtout on le verra
la télé dimanche soir au journal de tf1
le mardi
là sa grande réunion à la mutualité où
ils devraient me dire plein de choses
alors vous allez pouvoir
oui c'est fillon le retour alors mais
jusqu'ici ils avaient peut-être laissé
un petit peu trop de l'espace à son
rival
il était temps qu'ils s'y mettent
aujourd'hui sa parole est attendue
clermont et ils vous allez l'entendre à
partir de dimanche donc je crois qu'il
faut pas être impatient il va parler
il va parler très bientôt et vous savez
ce qui va nous dire ah la mutualité ou à
la télévision même déjà dimanche est-ce
qu'il va partir nous parler des
élections de la primaire pour 2017
vous savez vous savez françois fillon a
abordé tous les derniers les dernières
échéances y compris le scrutin interne à
l'ump avec une certaine vision de la
france et de la politique que nous
devions mener
donc je crois qu'il parlera de la france
et il parlera aussi de ce qu'il souhaite
faire dans les mois qui viennent et dans
les années qui viennent
justement à propos de leurs deux mois
qui viennent
on sait qu'en septembre enfin bruxelles
ou d'ailleurs je pose la question en
septembre prochain on aura bien une
élection à nouveau pour le président ump
pour ramener la paix dans l'ump
nous avons fait un accord et cet accord
prévoit des élections en 70 ans du des
choses ici là sera peut-être bien après
tout on a le statut quo tout va bien
maintenant dans notre parti alors
pourquoi remettre ça sur le tapis
oui mais la paix c'est lié à l'accord et
l'accord la condition d'accord c'est un
nouveau vote
donc nous aurons dans ses habitants
est-ce que conseilleriez à monsieur
fillon d'être à nouveau candidat pour
cette élection
oui moi je souhaite qu'il soit à nouveau
candidat à cette élection parce que pour
moi c'est assez légitime
je pense que la france a besoin de lui
je pense que l'opposition a besoin car
c'est quand même un risque parce que
monsieur copé auprès des militants il a
aussi du succès les deux ont du succès
est la preuve que répondre puisque je
fais pas 50 50 au mois de novembre
dernier donc c'est vrai que c'est un
risque pour monsieur fillon
mais vous lui conseillé d'y aller et si
des fois ils n'y allaient pas voyez je
vois plus loin encore est ce que
quelqu'un d'autre pourrait y aller
monsieur wauquiez peut-être laurent
wauquiez on vous même pour l'instant je
ne fais pas de fiction
j'attends la décision de françois fillon
en juin mais pas comme ces
interrogations est ce que ça ne relance
pas toujours les critiques sur la
velléité de l'ancien premier ministre
on l'attendait à paris bon il sera pas
candidat à la mairie on était même pas
s'il va se représenter donc à la
présidence de l'ump
mais je commence qu'il doit s'y prendre
aujourd'hui pour corriger cette
impression là je vais vous donner le
faut et ma pensée je pense que quand on
va dans une élection comme celle de
maire de paris
on y va pour être maire de paris à
plein-temps pleinement pendant des
années pour mener un projet pour cette
ville et on s'y consacre à fond je pense
qu'on ne peut pas gagner par ah bon
autre exemple pendant ce délai mais
combien de mandat de maire de paris avec
l'objectif quand même
même pas raté 15 morts à excuser moi
quand jacques chirac se présente à paris
si je ne me trompe pas c'était dans 77
villes à quatre ans avant lesquels il va
complètement se consacrer à paris et il
va faire de très belles choses à paris
effectivement il ne cache pas ses
ambitions nationales mais il va
consacrer un temps important à paris je
crois qu'aujourd'hui les électeurs ne
supporte pas
j'allais dire les zappeurs
professionnels ceux qui vont d'élection
en élection et mû uniquement par leur
ambition donc je crois que celui qui te
vas gagner paris qui doit gagner paris
doit s'engager complètement pour paris
c'est pour ça que si françois fillon
souhaite et moi je le souhaite parce que
je pense que la france a besoin de lui
s'engager pour la france qu'il ne peut
pas s'engager pour paris d'accord mais
nous on savait sans calcul également bon
alors je crois que les parisiens ne
l'aurait pas accepté
enfin je lui ferai quand même trois ans
pour se consacrer à paris vous parliez
des quatre ans tout à l'heure de
monsieur chirac mai de 14 à 17 il ya
trois ans c'est très peu ne serait ce
que pour réparer tous les dommages
causés à paris par bertrand delanoë
parce qu'aujourd'hui on voit bien la
fermeture des voies sur berge par
exemple cause des nuisances intolérable
à la fois aux parisiens et aux habitants
de la banlieue natale et jusqu'au
morizet elle a annoncé sa candidature à
paris est ce que votre avis c'est une
mauvaise nouvelle pour la gauche je
pense qu'on peut gagner paris je pense
que nous aurons des bons candidats pour
mener la bataille à paris la seule chose
que je veux dire c'est forte de mon
expérience des primaires internes que
j'ai vécues aux régionales par exemple
c'est qu'il nous faut des primaires
sereine à paris pour préserver nos
chances de victoire
et il faut aussi que l'organisation de
ces primaires soit exemplaire parce que
c'est la première j'ai l'iran
organisation de scrutin j'ai des
bisbilles pourtant oui il faut que ce
soit exemplaire je fais confiance à la
fédération de paris pour les organiser
mais il faut que ces primaires soit
exemplaire parce que c'est le premier
scrutin
nous avons après le désastreux spectacle
de novembre dernier
donc nous devons faire en sorte que ces
primaires soient exemplaires sereine et
qu'il n'y ait pas de coups en dessous de
la ceinture contrairement à ce qui s'est
passé aux régionales de 2010
à votre avis nathalie kosciusko morizet
qui est une écologiste reconnu est
convaincue elle plus à craindre un
affrontement avec anne hidalgo ou bien
avec une candidature éventuelle de
cécile duflot puisque le lait mme duflot
a dit rien n'était exclu pour moi la
vraie adversaire c'est anne hidalgo
c'est anne hidalgo et derrière anne
hidalgo bertrand delanoë
avec aujourd'hui un bilan qui est avec
beaucoup plus de point négatif que de
positif et je pense que c'est ça qu'il
faut qu'il faut attaquer je pense
qu'aujourd'hui par exemple la pénurie de
logements à paris est patente
il aurait fallu transformer tous les
bureaux qui ont été construits en
logement benoist apparu l'avait déjà
proposé il y l'année dernière et je
crois qu'il faut que nous nous
attaquions à cette pénurie de logements
il ya quelques jours alain du alain
juppé a dit sentir non vie chez monsieur
sarkozy de revenir sur le devant de la
scène
je sais que vous rencontrez souvent où
vous aussi le président sarkozy enfin
l'ancien président sarkozy est ce que
vous sentez la même chose
moi je ne lis pas dans le marc de café
et le président sarkozy ne m'a pas fait
de confidences
donc je lui laisse je vais dire le choix
de 2 de son avenir
je crois que c'est ce qu'il souhaite son
coeur et son esprit
non non je vous dis gemini dans le marc
de café
nés dans le monde après jean les arts ou
dans les cerveaux on a quand même
l'impression finalement à l'ump que tout
autour du silence ou de l'absence de
monsieur sarkozy on pourra dire plus
d'ailleurs que c'est un silence
assourdissant et une absence
omniprésente ainsi si j'ose dire je ne
partage pas cet avis et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il ya toute une
génération de cadrage nerfs qui est en
train de prendre ses marques à l'ump de
proposer de mûrir d'aller dans des
combats difficiles et à qui est précieux
pour chacun d'entre nous le regarde le
parrainage et éventuellement un certain
nombre de conseils
s'il souhaite revenir ce sera son choix
mais ce sera évidemment ça ne l'est pas
aujourd'hui c'est le moment que vous
avez ce parrainage nous mêmes et vous
recevez ses conseils
écoutez je ne reçois pas gelé celui ci
pouvait solliciter bac à mousse ont
distribué volontiers donc enfin je veux
contrôler la dernière question de neige
justement vous nous parliez des quadras
ou des cadres à je ne sais pas trop
comment il faut dire bien je vais vous
poser une question à ce propos vous
faites partie de ce qu'on appelle des
les cadres à les quadras côtés de
laurent wauquiez françois baroin xavier
bertrand bruno le maire est vous êtes
l'ump de demain la droite est
aujourd'hui aussi de celle de demain est
ce que vous sentez que la construit la
concurrence va être dure entre vous
d'abord ce que je ressens c'est c'est
c'est un devoir le devoir de construire
une alternative à la politique de
françois hollande je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure qu'il me paraissait totalement
sans cap et sans boussole économique la
france aujourd'hui est en train de se
paupériser les entreprises s'en vont on
a beaucoup parlé de gérard depardieu et
de son départ
à la noël mais ça n'est que la partie
émergée de l'iceberg le vrai souci
aujourd'hui c'est toutes ces entreprises
qui prennent leurs décisions d'investir
ailleurs
et oui mais c'est sa manière aux quadras
entre vous qu'est ce qui se passe mais
un mélange et le syli temps géologiques
je ne suis pas dans une logique
d'ambition madame déjà que je suis
normal que vous soyez ambitieux ce
précieux outil qui non mais je suis
d'abord dans une
ic de d'aider mon pays de le protéger de
le sauver de proposer qu'une ambition
oui c'est une énorme ambition c'est
peut-être même une ambition plus noble
que l'ambition personnelle
on va y revenir dans un instant avec
perrine tarneaud de public sénat qui va
nous rejoindre merci nadège avant cela
avec sophie normand on va revenir sur
votre parcours et léry pécresse la
politique vous avez cité d'ailleurs le
combat des régionales en île de france
vous avez cité la guerre des chefs à la
tête de l'ump il ya quelques mois pour
vous là semblent la politique semble
avoir plus que d'autres peut-être été
une confrontation avec la violence en
politique on voit ça donc avec sophie
normand elle est combative valérie
pécresse
le mot revient dans la bouche des
membres de sa famille l'ump comme de ses
opposants
un trait de caractère qu'elle s'est
forgée dès ses premières campagnes
politiques
elle a été élue députée lorsque la
parité n'était pas aussi évidente que
cela il ya dix ans qu'il fallait
lorsqu'on était une femme faire son
chemin de la détermination il lui en a
fallu pour affronter les régionales ou
encore plus récemment la crise à l'ump
c'est au prix d'un long feuilleton
marquant qu'elle est devenue secrétaire
général délégué du parti
c'est des moments qui pour nous tous ont
été très durs très durs parce qu'il y
avait ce climat terrible entre nous
parce qu'il y avait ces tensions à
l'intérieur de l'ump parce qu'il y avait
ces soupçons de triche et
d'irrégularités qui était très fort
valérie jamais lâché et surtout on a été
très soudés dans cette période c'est à
dire que nous on a travaillé très
fortement équipés en étant très
rassemblée et je pense que c'est ce
trait de caractère qui a été révélé à ce
moment là chez valérie c'est une façon
de ne pas la chaîne dans l'épreuve
valérie pécresse c'est aussi cette
génération formée par nicolas sarkozy de
ses années comme ministre côté de
l'ancien chef de l'état
elle aurait conservé une appétence
particulière pour la communication
pas vraiment du goût de son principal
opposant au conseil régional d'île de
france
je pense que c'est vraiment un choix
politique de sa part d'être dur est de
ce point de vue là je pense qu'elle a
beaucoup irrité nicolas sarkozy c'est à
dire je pense que nicolas sarkozy a été
le grand instituteur même si les aimait
pas beaucoup
la droite est à les amatrices et même
pour une valérie pécresse qui vient du
chiraquisme au départ sur l'idée que la
politique c'est d'abord trois phrases
qui passent à la télévision sont un
angle très prononcé qui donne une
identité entre guillemets et qu'il faut
se tenir à ça absolument et ne jamais
apparaître comme étant quelqu'un capable
de complexité la complexité finalement
nuit à la politique nicolas sarkozy
un coach pour valérie pécresse celui qui
s'est promis de ne plus intervenir dans
le débat public reste néanmoins très
présent auprès des quadras de l'ump
notamment
c'est lui qui les pousserait à monter en
puissance voilà dernière partie de cette
émission avec vos valérie pécresse dans
matrix et par nicolas sarkozy je sais
pas comment vous l'entendez matrix et
par nicolas sarkozy d'abord je pense
être une enfant adoptée de la sarkozie
je suis d'abord un bébé chirac et celui
qui m'a vraiment formés en politique il
s'appelle jacques chirac et il avait une
vision de la politique qui pouvait être
combattantes mais qui était aussi très
humaine oui il faut grimper marche par
marche jaillir mais il disait aussi il
faut aimer les gens et nicolas sarkozy
ne disait pas la même chose nicolas
sarkozy il était plus dans le meilleur
quand je les connais ils étaient plus
dans le combat dans le combat pour
lutter contre la crise donc il était
plus effectivement dans une notion de
combat et de protéger les français
donc c'était s'était il n'était pas dans
le même registre tout à fait les deux
pour revenir sur les moments de violence
en politique évoquée notamment dans ce
reportage
laurent wauquiez est ce que c'est cette
violence en politique ça vous à sa
pugnacité un moment ou à un autre à
vouloir raccrocher
c'est très vite cette tentation là c'est
très dur pour une femme d'être
confrontés à la violence de ses amis
quand c'est son propre camp qui vous
attaquent mais aussi voyez simplement la
rue moi moi j'ai eu 9 mois de mouvement
universitaire on m'a confié la réforme
la plus difficile à mettre en oeuvre
celle qui avait fait sauter tous les
nuits la réforme l'univers
étaient 170 évacuation de fac à faire
donc vraiment la question de résister à
la rue j'ai eu des manifestants en face
de moi avec des battes de base-ball j'ai
été menacé physiquement donc s'élever la
tentation de renoncer écoutez je ne
savais pas que j'avais en moi ses
ressources mais je les ai trouvés et je
pense que la politique offre tellement
de demandes ire de de motivation
intrinsèque c'est à dire qu'on est pas
mal tellement le sentiment d'être utiles
on a tellement le sentiment de de
pouvoir peser sur le cours des choses et
que ça s'il ya très peu de métier qui
donne ce sentiment là donc ça compense
largement la dureté de cette vie
politique je ne sais pas ça ne compense
pas toujours et c'est vrai qu'il ya des
moments où on se dit pourquoi tant de
violence mois en décembre
j'étais malheureuse j'étais malheureuse
pour les électeurs de l'ump j'étais
malheureux du spectacle qu'ont donnés
j'aurais tellement aimé que tout ça ne
sera pas aussi violent que effectivement
à ce moment là on doute mais mais bon on
peut vous avez été moins violente que le
camp d'en face vous même personnellement
mais le sujet de l'apparition dans les
médias notamment oui mais quand vous
êtes ap dans une spirale de violence en
réalité même si vous même vous essayer
d'apaiser les choses
la violence rejaillit sur vous savez
vous êtes vous êtes vous être taché par
la violence même quand elle vient de
l'adversaire c'est c'est normal vous
avez été beaucoup caricaturé comme
d'autres un pendant toute cette période
là pendant tout cet automne lors de
cette bataille fratricide au sein de
l'ump on avait beaucoup souffert
la politique la politique ça nécessite
de 2,2 ce cas rappaz sonné alors ça veut
pas dire qu'à l'intérieur on doit pas
garder une forme de sensibilité et
notamment des coûte aux autres et je
crois que c'est très important la
curiosité les couteaux des autres la
volonté de changer les choses ça on doit
le garder en jogging par d'idéalisme si
on n'y a pas une part d'idéalisme une
part dans vie
je pense qu'on devient vite et gris et
l'aigreur ou l'amertume
ça fait des mauvais politique voyez
quand même eu des amitiés qui se sont
défaits des 10 et des désillusions aussi
sans doute peut-être un peu trop d'ego
vous avez été une des premières même la
première de la bande des mousquetaires a
rallié non pas jean françois copé mais
françois fillon jean françois copé il a
été beaucoup affecté par le fait que
vous françois baroin allait plutôt vers
vers françois fillon est ce que depuis
vous en avait parlé avec copé qu'est-ce
que vous avez un peu crever cet abcès là
mais il faut savoir que d'abord l'amitié
ça nécessite de la réciprocité
voilà et quand on est amis et bien on
respecte l'autre et on respecte sa
décision et ses jeux respecter l'autre
je le pense mais je ne veux pas refaire
l'histoire
mon choix pour françois fillon c'était
un choix d'abord politique j'étais très
proche de françois fillon proches de
jean-françois mes proches je cite
françois
j'ai fait un choix politique parce que
je pense qu'aujourd'hui celui qui peut
nous faire gagner en 2017
il s'appelle françois fillon mais perry
nouveau posé la question à vous si vous
êtes se réconcilier à l'occasion je ne
sais pas d'une rencontre avec jean pour
ta copé mais jean-françois copé et moi
maintenant nous avons des relations qui
sont à la fois très lucide on se connaît
depuis longtemps et en même temps des
relations de travail
on se connaît on a travaillé ensemble
depuis dix ans donc on sait travailler
ensemble aura toujours une méfiance
désormais mais c'est pas désormais
monsieur grossiord c'est déjà sur nos
relations étaient ce qu'elles étaient
avant et je ne referai pas l'histoire je
ne vois qu'on n'aurait pas mal alors
reparler la région ile-de-france valérie
pécresse de questions sur les transports
alors que la patience de beaucoup de
voyageurs en ile de france commence à
être à bout tout d'abord les décisions
autour du super métro autour de paris
vont être annoncées par le premier
ministre le 6 mars mais ce qu'on a
encore les moyens de le réaliser ce
super métro oui bien sûr on a les moyens
tout est une question de choix
vous savez que on peut avoir le choix de
baisser les tarifs des transports
c'est ce que jean paul huchon appelle le
pass navigo à tarif unique où on dirait
à tous les franciliens vous payer 65
euros pour votre pass navigo et ses
tarifs et licques ça coûte 500
d'euros par semestre examiner et à la
ratp
voilà c'est à coups de 500 me medeau
rayonnement il survit sur wii parce que
sur 20 ans si vous faites 500 millions
d'euros de pertes pour la sncf la ratp
ça coûte 10 milliards qu'est ce que je
pense je pense qu'il faut faire le choix
de l'avenir pas le choix de la démagogie
le choix de l'avenir ces deux nouvelles
lignes ces deux nouvelles rames
c'est la rénovation totale de nos
transports ça coûtera 10 milliards de
plus que prévu c'est vrai mais si on s'y
met tous
si on s'y met tous on peut obtenir en
2030 d'avoir tout rénové et peut-être en
2020 d'avoir toutes les rames neuves en
ile de france
je crois que c'est vraiment très
important les transports c'est de la
qualité de vie c'est de la croissance
c'est l'investissement dans la région
c'est du logement où elle continue
minutes pour l'annoncer je lui fais pas
totalement confiant c'est pour ça que
j'ai demandé à tous les élus ump de
signer avec moi une lettre où nous lui
proposons des ressources supplémentaires
pour financer le grand paris et j'espère
qu'ils nous entendra parce que je pense
qu'il faut faire preuve d'imagination je
pense qu'on peut pas sacrifier le grand
paris parce que le grand paris c'est
c'est vraiment l'avenir des franciliens
dans dix ans mais c'est aussi l'avenir
de nos enfants demain c'est votre avenir
politique aussi peut-être un peu mais
vous savez porter une vision pour une
région porte et guillon peut-être et
j'espère porter cette région est
justement moi je ne veux pas la porte et
en ayant une vision uniquement
clientéliste de saupoudrage de crédit je
donne à une association je donne à une
commune c'est pas ma vision de la région
ce que je voudrais c'est bâtir
je voudrais construire une nouvelle
région où il y aurait du logement mais
avec des transports du 2 de l'emploi à
proximité tout ça ça se construit ça se
dessine c'est ça être président de
région et si j'étais président de la
région de france c'est comme ça que je
gère la région avec une vision de
l'avenir
vous êtes candidate on a compris ça vous
savez en tout cas le pass navigo unique
vous dites que ça fait petit temps la
proposition de jean paul huchon et de
cécile duflot faim pendant les
régionales les dernières semaines
vrai prix du pass navigo à tarif unique
c'est 90 euros par mois
c'est insoutenable de dire aux français
hier vous allez payer 90 euros si on le
met à 65
c'est démagogique ces 500 millions
d'euros de manque à gagner pour la sncf
et la ratp par an c'est le chiffre qu'a
donné jean paul huchon
je ne sais pas on trouvera ses 500
millions et ce que je pense c'est que
les franciliens aujourd'hui ce qu'ils
veulent c'est des transports qui
arrivent à l'heure qu'ils soient
confortables qui soit fiable des
nouvelles lignes des nouvelles rames
c'est certainement pas en priorité payer
moins cher et justement deux petites
questions pour finir toujours sur les
transports vous avez dénoncé le scandale
du bonus régularité des conducteurs de
rer qui poussent des trains ne pas
s'arrêter dans certaines gares vous avez
demandé leur annulation
leur annulation qu'en est il aujourd'hui
les ondes et jacadi arrêter ça j'avais
des patrons juifs mais rien n'est clair
sur cette affaire parce qu'il ya deux
versions contradictoires de la version
des journalistes qui disent qu
effectivement ils ont vu le train ne pas
s'arrêter pour des pour tenir ses
objectifs de régularité et la version du
syndicat des transports d'ile-de-france
présidé par jean paul huchon qui nous
dit mais c'est faux c'est une
manipulation journalistique
je ne sais pas ce qui est vrai j'ai
demandé une commission denquête nous
devons savoir ce qui se passe et s'il ya
des bus et des tramways et rer qui ne
s'arrête pas dans certaines gares pour
remplir leur contrat avec le syndicat
des transports
et bien c'est inacceptable pour les
voyageurs et il faut absolument qu'on
les sanctionne une question sur paris la
fermeture des voies sur berge un manuel
valls mise à l'intérieur dit attention à
ne pas pénaliser les habitants de
banlieue vous êtes trouvé un nouvel
allié dans cette histoire et bien si
manuel valls est mon allié moi je lui
demande que le préfet de police publie
qui dépend lui qui dépendent de lui que
le préfet de police de paris publie les
statistiques des embouteillages les
statistiques des pollutions les
statistiques des reports de circulation
qui sont dues à la fermeture des voies
sur berges et si ces nuisances sont
intolérables ce que je crois pour les
parisiens et pour les banlieusards que
le préfet de police demandent l'arrêt de
ce projet de monsieur delanoë donc
rendre et les chiffres publics mais
beaucoup tapé sur le gouvernement depuis
le début cette émission on rappelle
qu'il ya des militaires français qui
sont agréés engagé au mali il ya une
opération qui a été menée dans le nord
du pays une vingtaine d'islamistes qui
ont été tuées dans les fameuses
montagnes du nord et un soldat français
a été tué là au moins vous
pour rappeler qu'il il ya des moments où
célébrer l'union nationale canadienne
entendu l'action de françois hollande
comme chef de guerre l'unité nationale
derrière le soldat est indispensable et
ça n'empêche pas que nous ayons un
soutien toujours vigilant gouvernement
merci encore une fois
valérie pécresse d'avoir été avec nous
aujourd'hui et la semaine prochaine et
bien nous serons salon de l'agriculture
notre invité sera didier guillaume
vice-président du sénat et président du
conseil général de la drôme bonsoir à
tout ça très vite
depuis l'accident de fukushima la
question du risque nucléaire a refait
surface en france les recours massif à
la sous-traitance commence à poser
problème
on est obligé d'aller vite pour toujours
huit villes c'est sans arrêt sous
pression sous toujours les huit salariés
sous pression sous payés et aux cadences
infernales la rentabilité prend le pas
sur la sécurité
si demain il aurait eu un accident
nucléaire on va nous dire que c'est nous
les prestataires qui sommes responsables
enquête sur un phénomène et ses
conséquences nucléaires la bombe humaine
samedi à 22 heures sur public sénat
quelque part ne pas connaître l'histoire
des noirs de france et enlever un des
pans de notre récit comment on ne
comprend rien aux siècles 17e ou 18e se
comprend pas la place qu'elles esclavage
on comprend rien au 19e siècle si on ne
comprend pas l'émergence d'élites noir
aussi bien au sein de l'armée française
que dans nos universités que en tant que
grand avocat haïtien par exemple qui à
paris se battent à la fin 19e pour
défendre des idées d'égalité et on ne
comprend rien 20e siècle on l'a au moins
se comprend pas que pendant deux
conflits ces présences ont été
déterminantes si on ne comprend pas la
vie intellectuelle l'histoire de la
négritude sur ne comprend pas d'une
certaine manière que notre pays s'est
fait ensemble
et bien cette histoire l'a fait que de
comprendre au mieux notre histoire
commune effectivement sur la question de
la communauté noire c'est une
construction de perception plus qu'une
réalité objective
quand vous disiez que votre gaston
kelman y avait une différence évidente
effectivement nous n'appartenons pas la
même génération
je suis né ici vous avez connu un
parcours migratoire je suis aussi une
femme le fait d'être une femme noire
s'est encore passé pas la même chose que
le fait d'être un homme noir on a une
perspective complètement différente et
les témoignages montrent justement la
complexité de cette figure noire qu'on
aime réduira son essence et on c'est à
dire que il ya un livre qui s'appelle on
ne naît pas noir on le devient moi je
suis né en france et j'ai découvert que
j'étais noir lorsque j'étais petit parce
qu'on me l'a fait remarquer mais quand
on est dans un petit enfant français on
ne se pensent ni blanc ni noir c'est le
regard extérieur qui nous construit
comme cela et qui fait que finalement on
va soit le revendiquer soient contestées
le statut qui nous est associée du fait
de nos couleurs moroses et moi mais vous
voyez vos parents vous voyez les parents
et les enfants
vous savez je vais vous donner je peux
vous donner un exemple j'ai une amie qui
enseigne en école maternelle
un jour un petit garçon est venu la voir
en me disant son camarade l'embêter et
le monde quelques camarades tambay t
elle dit c'est le noir alors on cherche
à cacher j'avais un peu embêté et c est
en fait ils trouvent que le noir en
question était un petit enfant blanc qui
avait une veste noire
les enfants ne perçoivent pas les
couleurs de peau la même manière que
nous je pense que c'est quelque chose
qui est passé à priori là on a vraiment
une différence à la couleur de peau moi
j'ai grandi dans
heureusement dans le nord de paris dans
un environnement où j'étais dans un
immeuble où la majorité des gens étaient
issues étaient d'origine asiatique et
venait en fait des communautés qui
étaient venus avec les boat people
je me suis jamais posé la question de
notre différence effectivement la
contraire le dit en riant devient noir
et à partir de là c'est le choix qu'ont
fait après et c'est parfois là que ça
change
moi je considère que à la naissance du
mouvement cependant la négritude c'était
presque incontournable que de se fonder
sur cette espèce de de cataplasme
d'ectoplasmes qu'on avait construit
parce que le problème du noir c'est que
c'est pas lui qui définit comme noir le
problème de noir c'est que quelqu'un de
petits décide un jour qu'il est noir
avec tout ce que cela porte derrière
delahaye peut-être les nuances apportées
aujourd'hui où il ya des gens qui
revendiquent mais dans carré noir de la
naissance de la race noire pourrait dire
que c'est pas le noir qui au congo au
cameroun dit nous on est les noirs ils
sont congolais bantous et puis comme on
est tout ce qu'on veut mais un jour on
définit le noir dans une stratification
raciale où il ya le blanc le jaune le
rouge le noir est l'acte quand le noir
découvre les noirs soit avec la
négritude
ils se font dessus pour dire ok on est
noir mais en revendique ses six titres
sont énormes on a une culture une
civilisation
alors est-ce que ça a été tirée presque
un risque pour vous qui êtes de guyane
est ce que vous êtes dit attendez nous
on est français on est d'un département
français on n'a rien à voir avec les
noirs qui viennent par exemple je parle
du manioc d'ailleurs et qui sont venus
soit au titre de saint-claude niçois
tout simplement en immigration de
travail en france je pense qu'à un
moment de l'histoire
et effectivement les antilles et les
guyanais les réunionnais j'ai senti un
peu à part en disant qu'ils étaient
certainement noir mais qu'ils étaient
avant tout français et par la suite il
faut le constater les noirs tous les
noirs de france se sent tous sentis
pareil subissant les mêmes
discriminations en termes d'emploi et de
logement
et on arrive actuellement
faire partie de cette communauté si je
peux employer ce terme cette communauté
de noirs de france
alors voir de france marc en france vous
vous revendiquez votre appartenance aux
origines qu'un monet c'est ça oui
cameroun est justement mêmes bas ça
pourrait la profondeur bantous tout ce
qu'on veut sauf noir moi je dis que je
voudrais ccdh et noir je voudrais te
nomme tout simplement il faudra quinze
jours
l'intégrité ne soit plus un critère des
définitions de l'individu passe
aujourd'hui comme nous tous nous sommes
d'accord sur un point ici on est d'abord
noir avant d'être autre chose hélas
alors que je souhaite être autre chose
je voudrais sur comment je suis devenu
noir quand c'est d'arriver en france
c'est là qu'on m'a dit les noirs font
comme ceci au cameroun on me disait les
camerounais sont comme si c'est les
bassins sont comme cela mais je n'avais
jamais appris que les noirs avaient une
ligne directrice parce que quand tu
avais musulman je le traitais de
musulmans cq61 communauté noire elle
s'agrègent dans l'adversité contre les
blancs on va dire de cette façon nous
nions pas les ordures et c'est une
fiction pour moi vraiment la communauté
noire est une fiction
nous avons vu la multiplicité c'est à
dire c'est le fondement est faux il est
fictif définir déjà comme des noirs le
bambara qui exactement comme le type de
ma table et on regrette aussi que
l'europe avance méritée doigt une
communauté noire vont desservir son
histoire et nous visons à sortir moi
personnellement je ne demande qu'à
sortir de 2,7 livrer ce fan on l'appelle
à livrer la livre et qu'on m'a mise qui
seraient porteuses de d'activer bien
spécifique et puis de qualités des
défauts bien spécifiques il ya une
réalité quand même aimé voir en france
et peut-être pas une communauté noire
mais une réalité des lois en france qui
ont les mêmes problèmes
il faut être concret il faut gérer un
problème les problèmes problèmes
matériels l'emploi le logement les
difficultés qu'ont les noirs de trop
autres à trouver il a trouvé un logement
d'emploi travailleurs immigrés qui a
fait des séries les noirs ont d'entrée
souvent on en fait référence quand il
s'agit
de grands écrivains de grands
intellectuels le grand sportif de grands
artistes mais il faudrait effectivement
qu'on parle également du noir normal
puisqu'il faut employer ce terme est
très à la mode le noir normal le noir
normal comment est il perçu en france
bon dans votre ouvrage est très bien bon
c'est vrai qu'on va donc en chine